from the start of Demon Slayer we're
shown that becoming a demon is basically
the most horrific thing that can
possibly happen to a human being because
even though they gain superhuman
strength speed and healing demons lose
every bit of their Humanity plus it
looks pretty painful and so when rengoku
rejected the chance to become a powerful
demon during the Mugen train Arc he
showed us that he would rather die than
become a demon but what if rangako had
actually decided to live on and continue
fighting as a demon let's rewind here
akaza punches a hole through rengoku's
stomach and once again offers to turn
him into a demon with tanjiro screaming
in the background rengoku realizes that
he is going to die as you'll remember in
the original story rengoku accepted his
fate with open arms but let's imagine
for a second that ringoku shows some
vulnerability and doesn't want to die
here perhaps he clings onto life with
every fiber of his being rude refusing
to accept his inevitable fate or maybe
he is determined to continue his fight
against demons and is willing to undergo
the ultimate and painful sacrifice to
gain the power to do so and as a result
this time ringoku accepts offer with a
wicked smile akaza infuses rangoku with
enough of the Demon King's Bloods to
start his transformation into a demon
and while this antagonizing process
begins the sun begins to rise as well
and with his last moments of Sanity
rangoku promises kanjiro and the others
that he will come back one day to fight
by their side again and the moment that
the Sun starts to creep across the
Horizon akasa mocks this promise and
then quickly carries rengoku into the
safety of the Dark Forest now we do know
from later on in the manga that super
powerful humans like the hashira can
actually take a few days to fully
transform into a demon and so akaza
takes renuku somewhere safe and isolated
during his transformation process May a
dark cave or in a bad house somewhere
who knows however since akasa selfishly
wanted rengoku to be his own personal
sparring partner let's assume that he
does not take rengoku back to the Demon
King buzon right away and instead keeps
him far enough away that muzan remains
unaware of rangoku's transformation for
now so a few days pass and the newly
formed demon rengoku finally awakens
this Valley has dramatically transformed
with razor-sharp spikes terrifying horns
and a swirling flame pattern along his
skin and like any new demon the first
thing that he really craves is food and
now of course the possibilities of this
insane what-if scenarios can branch in
many many different directions you see
we already know that demons will
sometimes just completely lose their
human memories after the transition and
so it's completely possible that the
rengoku could completely forget who he
was and become a ruthless evil demon who
eventually will serve buza on the other
hand though as We Know know some demons
do keep their memories or eventually
recover them over time so let's assume
that rangoku's crazy strength and
discipline will enable him to hold at
least some of his Humanity despite his
new demon 4. but the Cravings that come
with his new demon form begin to drive
him insane the hunger eats at his
insides and his body grows weaker by the
hour and still rengoku refuses to give
in to his demon desires and he refuses
to eat anything that akaza brings him
now akazah who thinks that humans are
pitiful and weak gross increasingly and
raged by rengoku's Defiance he just
wants to fight him again and so the air
crackles with tension as both rengoku
and akazah find themselves eager to
fight rengoku desires nothing more than
to kill akaza for Revenge while the
other demon is determined to beat the
humanity out of his new super strong
adversary and so they do clash with
rengoku using a brand new blade of black
Flames made from his blood's demon meant
art but despite gaining the usual
Supernatural strength speed and healing
of a demon rangoku struggles heavily to
keep up with akaza's full power which he
never actually displayed during the
Mugen train incident in the first place
rangoku fiercely fights against his
demonic cravings for days as akas
attempts him with human flesh the two
demons keep on battling every single
night and rangoku's will to hold on to
his Humanity starts to weaken akasa
warns him that muzan will kill him if he
ever thinks about betraying the demons
and rangoku knows that he won't be able
to hide his intentions from muzan's mind
reading abilities there is literally
nothing rengoku will be able to do
except for one thing which is gonna be
very animish rangoku grows weak from
hunger and decides to end his pitiful
existence as a demon by stepping into
the sunlight but just before he can do
that akas attempt him with some more
food and this time renko failing Spirit
snaps as he indulges his demonic needs
his human memory starts to face they are
locked deep within his mind and he eats
in order to stay alive in other words
the denguku's transformation into a
demon is now complete and so now let's
shift over to the Demon Slayer core
where rangoku's betrayal leaves the
group absolutely devastated and of
course there are many ways that the
demon Slayers could approach this
terrible situation but no matter what
the loss of one of their strongest
Warriors is a terrible blow made all the
way worse by the knowledge that they now
serve their greatest enemy it is likely
at this point that rengoku's father
would commit satuku in shame and we have
to imagine that the rest of the demon
Slayers are in chaos as well because
from the manga we know that one of
muzan's eventual goals is to find the
Demon Slayer base and wipe all of them
out with one pulse white and since
rengoku knows where the Mansion is
kagaya ubayashiki the leader of the the
demon Slayers could be incredibly
worried about muzan being able to learn
this information and he could consider a
few options here such as ordering
everyone to leave and set up a new base
somewhere else or he might simply think
that strengthening their current base is
the best option here because it is
basically already the most demon-proof
area in the world so let's just assume
for now that they chose to stay here and
that they have an intense debate about
what to do regarding rengoku some of the
hashira like sanami the windhashira or
yield the water hashira would probably
demand that they hunt him down for his
betrayal others like tanjiro and maybe
yo Mei the stonehashira could argue that
they need to talk with rangoku to see if
they could bring him back to their side
somehow and tanzuro is of course
extremely concerned about what will
happen when the demon Slayers eventually
confront rangoku again and so keep
watching to see how this epic Clash will
turn out later on in this video but
before the group can separate for the
next missions I definitely think that in
this situation Tantra would ask
permission to see Lady Tamayo who is the
demon lady who is working on a cure to
turn Demons back into people to see if
she has made any progress on the
life-changing medicine however very
likely it still isn't ready at this
point so tantiro vows to continue to
send her demon Bloods to continue with
her research and with rengoku now a
fully fledged demon akaza would
definitely take him to finally
and wow is the Demon King furious with
akazah for making rengoku a demon
without his permission it is entirely
possible that muzan could obliterate
both of them on the spot fearing that
the ringoku may eventually betray him or
become too powerful to control but for
now let's assume that he restrains
himself enough because he recognizes the
opportunity to gather more Intel about
the Demon Slayer core muzan attempts to
read rangoku's mind but he is incredibly
disappointed that rengoku has lost all
of those memories for now once more
muzan's temporary Knights but he spares
who's life for a reason that we will see
later on in this video because rangoku
was already super strong as a human I
think muzan would make him a lower Moon
one since that spot is now empty after
the Mugen train battle then rengoku is
sent out into the world and this is
where the story gets pretty damn dark at
this point the demon rangoku would be
hungry for power and would likely become
a terror in the human world he buries
his human shame and guilds deep
alongside his memories his dark Flames
consume everything in their path as he
Rampages through Village after Village
and this of course takes us to the
events of the Entertainment District Arc
which we saw in season 2 of the anime
now during this Arc tanjiro and the
others team up with the sound
hashiratengan and his ladies to take out
the upper Moon six demons daki and
yutorial and I think these events would
progress pretty much as they did in the
original story to a point in other words
tanjiro and the others investigate and
eventually uncover daki's presence they
epic battles the animation too good and
daki is almost killed until gutaro
reveals himself as well and just like in
the original daki's ability to use her
clothes as a weapon and yutara's
poisonous blades almost Wipe Out the
demon Slayers but eventually nizoku
awakens her next demon form and in the
end the demon Slayers are victorious
here and though badly injured the main
characters are still alive and tanjiro
even briefly awakened his Demon Slayer
Mark during the fight as well however
this is where things change because now
rengoku enters the fight as well you see
after all this time attacking humans and
even practicing against akazah rengoku
has grown extremely powerful at this
point much stronger than the upper Moon
six demons who were just defeated and so
it is the perfect opportunity for
rengoku to defeat the demon Slayers and
claim daki and yutaro's place within the
upper moons now and this is a truly
awful time for the demon slayer's first
confrontation with rangoku nizoku is
still recovered ring from nearly going
berserk tengen and inosuke are hanging
on by a threat tanjiro and zenitsu are
basically completely spent at this point
as well but none of that of course
matters to demon rangoku his black
Flames Begin to consume the town and
burn the people in sight completely
exhausted tanjido stands up wielding his
chip blade and confronts this new demon
but he nearly drops the sword when he
recognizes who arrived here in utter
disbelief tanjaro just stands there
Frozen gazing upon the terrifying
demonic form of rengoku and despite this
shock I still think that tanjiro would
somehow try to talk to him that is after
all tanjiro's main character trait that
he always believes in a person's
capability to be good and so tanjiro
fanatically calls Al turangoku begging
him to stop the destruction but rangoku
barely pays him any attention instead he
heads straight for tengen who is
writhing in pain due to the poison still
in his blood looking down on the sound
hashira rangoku's Flames flare and this
might stir memories and guilt within him
but demon rangoku is still focused on
his goals and pushes them back down he
raises his burning swords then swipes
down a Tenga tanjiro leaps forward
raising his sword to block the killing
blow but the force of this blow throws
tanjiro aside tengen is helpless at this
point and the slash just slices straight
through the South and with one Demon
Slayer Dead this is where the battle
would really heat up because as we've
seen with
far his rage comes spilling out vegoku
turns his Dark Souls ice on the young
Demon Slayer tanjiro shouts at his
former friends demanding that he
remembers himself bengaku loved people
he wanted nothing more than to protect
humans from demons but the demon rangoku
barely reacts to any of these words
instead he slowly starts approaching
tanzuro and with an unwavering courage
both zanitsu and inosuke stand beside
tanjudo even though they can barely even
move and together they face down their
most terrifying threat yet a form of
friends turned into a horrible heartless
monster they Clash for a brief moment
but the three of them are clearly no
match for the demon especially because
they were pushed to the limit in the
previous battle already even nasuku
tries joining the battle but she is also
completely exhausted so rengoku traps
all of them in a burning cage of black
flames and with no shred of humanity in
his eyes he raises his blade to strike
all of them down but then the wind
starts picking up the Flames Flicker and
suddenly the fire is gone and rengoku
vanishes at least as far as the three
young demon Slayers can tell sword
clashes start ringing out bursts of
flame and winds through the streets the
sound of gushing water around them and
suddenly everything stops on one end of
the street stands the demon rangoku
Bloods dripping and cuts healing in
front of tajiro stand you and sonami the
water and wind husher us breathing hard
and of course those two would not just
show up randomly I think it's entirely
possible that those two would have been
hunting rengoku this entire time and
have just managed to catch up to the
former hashira so you looks back at the
boys and would probably order them to
flee but sanami cares less about the
Younglings and stares down at the burned
corpse of tengen and his rage boils over
he shouts at rangoku cursing him and now
that they've tracked him down they are
going to end him rengoku however just
smirks Flames Rising up around him and
the battle resumes now zaitsu would
probably ask here if they should flee
but tanjiro of course and also inosuke
would not even respond to that as they
strain to keep up with the incredible
Display of Power in front of them and we
know from much later on in the story
that the upper Moon one two and three
demons are pretty far above the power
levels of the individual hashira and
while rangoku hasn't quite reached that
level yet he is certainly much stronger
than anything that the hashiras have
faced before so this definitely isn't
going to be an easy battle however at
the same time Gil and sanami are two of
the strongest hashira and together they
do manage to keep rengoku occupied they
do know that the sun is about to rise so
they must just stay alive until it
finally comes as the battle continues
the town Burns screams fill the air and
the hashidah are distracted by trying to
keep the innocent people alive at the
same time as facing rengoku meanwhile
the demon Delights in the chaos causing
more destruction with his flames and
amidst the burning Town tanjiro finds
himself torn here he does know that he
is completely outmatched in a battle on
this level but he cannot just stand by
and watch his friends parish as well and
despite it all he still refuses to give
up hope that the rengoku might not still
be saved but time is ticking away and in
the blink of an IQ is engulfed in flames
and sanami's attempt to save him earns
him a wicked slash across his leg the
two hashiras stumble and rangoku charges
towards them the battle picks up once
again but the hashira are clearly
beginning to lose their grip here and I
do think that it's at this point that
tanjiro would not be able to hold
himself back any longer as always when
he's the most desperate tanjaro finds
his next level of strength his heart
starts to race as he feels the rhythmic
powers of sun breathing filling his body
you cuts ringoku across the chest but
Flames explode from the wounds stunning
the water hashida rengoku grabs you by
the throat and squeezes tightly Gil
gasps his neck bulging but suddenly goo
is free and rengoku's severed hand falls
to the ground kanjiro now stands over a
breathless goo his demon Mark flaring on
his forehead giving him new strength to
fight rengoku grins blocking a blow from
sanami and then coming after tanjudo but
tanjiro is furious the rage fuels his
muscles and he leaps forward so quickly
that rangoku can barely block the
strikes and now together the three
demons layers rain blows on their former
friends with each strike tanjaro shouts
memories at rengoku reminding him of
their treasure time together how he
laughed with them how he trained with
them and how he was willing to give up
his life for them the memories fueled
Honduras Spirit but nothing seems to
break through to rengoku and still
Tundra of course keeps trying because
this demon was his friend and I don't
think that he would ever give up on him
but nonetheless at this point tanjiro is
slowing down exhausted he slips and gets
tossed to the side you and sonomi are
quickly downed as well they simply
cannot keep up with the stamina and
recovery of this overpowered demon so
rangaku now stands over them ready to
deliver the final blow but tanjiro Rises
One Last Time his sword is gone his
breaths are heavy his Sun breathing
flares and he stares the demon directly
in the eye and he does the only last
thing that he can do
yell yells Ren Goku's name over and over
again he repeats it trying to reach down
and awakened that buried memory because
just like he does with his sister nizuko
tanjiro has to believe that the human is
still buried inside somewhere of this
terrifying monster and with each time
rengoku's eyes grow unfocused the
Flaming sword lowers and suddenly tears
form in the dark pits of his eyes and a
word starts to form on his lips the
Flames falter sending me goes for
another strike but rangoku blocks it
sonemi his gaze turns to you and he
calls the water hashira's name as well
and then Goku the former flame hashira
drops his swords he stares at his hands
tears running down his face as he looks
at the demon Slayers in front of him
tanzido has finally reached him his
memories return but so do the shame and
guilt that he has been burying all this
time and with rangoku finally coming
back there are a few ways that this
could now go if he's truly returned the
demon Slayers could bring him back with
them however as we saw with sanami when
he first met nizuko when a demon kills a
human some hashira believed that there
is no forgiving that sin in any way and
so while emotions are overwhelming
ringoku sanami goes for a deathly strike
but tanjiro steps in front of him he
kneels before rengoku and tells him that
he can still choose to come back but
rangoku doesn't believe him his eyes
turn to tengen's Burnt body and his
cries grow even louder and he simply
asked sonomi to end him and the wind
hashira is more than willing to do so
until a haunting laugh Echoes down
streets
Musa has arrived because while muzan was
initially disappointed that he couldn't
get information about the demon Slayers
when they first met he probably knew
that at some point rengoku would regain
those memories and so he was just
waiting for the right moment all this
time and with rangoku's memories
returned muzan reads rangoku's mind and
finally learns the secret location of
the Demon Slayer core including where to
find their base the Demon Slayer is rice
tired and wrecked they face down the
Demon King muzan applauds rangoku
ironically for being so useful and then
he calls the former hashira to his side
he tells rengoku that he can use that
Guild and shame to grow much stronger
but rangoku does of course not listen
anymore at this point instead he rises
he backs everyone to flea reminding them
that the sun is about to rise and muzan
can stay here for long muzan scowls and
tries to trigger the curse that will
instantly kill rengoku but it doesn't
work with his memories fully returned
and his Humanity with it Goku's
connection to muzan has been severely
severed now we do know of course that
muzan is just insanely powerful way more
powerful than even the upper Moon demons
so it is entirely possible that he kills
all of them right here but to continue
the story let's assume that with the sun
close to Rising ringaku stands to face
the Demon King he tells the others to
run and without hesitation Gil and
sanami take the others and flee and I
would like to believe that rengoku would
at least be strong enough to hold the
king off for at least a short while
before muzan eventually ends the form of
flame hashira's life and with the sun
rising the demon Slayers manage to
retreat safely back to the Demon Slayer
core base but despite the hard-wrenching
tragedy of losing tengen and rengoku for
a second time there is no time to rest
with muzan now aware of their location
it would only be a matter of time before
the demons launch an all-out assault on
the Demon Slayer core and this insane
all-out battle will require tanjiro and
the other demons layers to summon every
ounce of their strength skill and
courage that they possess just to
survive this but one thing that we do
know is that tanjiro would never give up
on protecting his friends so he would
certainly unlock his full potential to
defeat the demon king or die trying and
if you want to see my full breakdown of
why this part of his character makes
tanjiro such a fantastic and great
protagonist you can watch right here
thanks for watching